the world's most controversial question
bizarrely has become what is a woman
we know that Nicholas sturgeon can't
answer that we know Kia starmer can't
answer that you're the British prime
minister what is a woman yeah I of
course I know a woman adult human female
and what you're actually now asking when
you ask that question is I I think you
know what's my Approach in view about
how we as a society grapple with a
situation where people are questioning
and wanting to change their gender their
ideas we must and should have enormous
compassion and tolerance and
understanding for those who are
questioning their gender and identity
and wanting to change and we will always
be supportive of that of course we will
and it's right to be compassionate about
that that's who we are as a people but
we have to recognize the challenges that
that poses particularly for women's
safety as we've just when you see indeed
that's why biological sex really matters